I'm your Ghost of Christmas Present.
Like "A Christmas Carol"?
On a bitter, cold Christmas Eve,
one dark soul is selected for redemption
by the Ghosts of Christmas Past,
Present, and Yet to Come.
A tradition that continues
to this very night.
Like "A Christmas Carol"?
Yes, yes! If you would just
let me get this out, sit.
So out of all the people on the planet,
murderers, people who do
gender reveal parties,
I'm the guy you're gonna haunt.
You know what? Forget it.
I told you. The guy is a level 20
pain in the Dickens.
Come on, I can take this guy.
I'm your Ghost of Christmas Present.
La, la, la, la. I'm not watching
your dramatic re-encrapment.
Hey, I'm haunting you!
You can't just run away from me
when I'm haunting you. Hello?
I believe he can be
a positive force for mankind.
And he's got his hands
all over everything.
Yeah, I wish.
-Maud, are you texting HR?
-No.
People don't change.
We got a runner!
That's just fun to watch.
I'm here to change him
to be a more positive force for humanity.
Clint?
Clint.
Yeah.
Did you Photoshop yourself
into these pictures of my Executive VP?
I don't think so.
Oh, you want that.
What I want is for you to shut up
and let me do my job.
Is there a Ghost of Christmas Grumpy?
Because you could do that job.
This is where real change begins.
Oh that's… oh, he's dead.
-Yeah, he's dead.
-Oh that… nope, he's fine. He's good.
-He's… wow, squirrely.
-None of it's real anyway.